un rassemblement du personnel
hospitalier vient de débuter devant
plusieurs hôpitaux à paris comme chaque
jeudi à l'espagne et en manifestent leur
colère contre le gouvernement
plus tôt dans la journée plusieurs
syndicats et collectifs hospitaliers ont
appelé le personnel et veilleux et les
usagers de l'hôpital à se mobiliser le
16 juin prochain
'l'annonce d'un hommage au personnel
soignant le 14 juillet lors d'une
cérémonie à la place d'un défilé
militaire n'a donc pas eu d'effet sur
ses appels à manifester pour les
personnels soignants le gouvernement
doit prendre en compte l'ensemble de
leurs revendications en plein c ur de la
santé aujourd'hui l'hôpital et malade
avec des conséquences terribles des
répercussions sur le système de santé
aujourd'hui à monsieur et madame qu'il
monte parce qu'il veut un rendez vous à
l'hôpital public
il doit attendre des mois et des mois
voire plus d'une année ça c'est pas
acceptable pour tous parce que c'est les
budgets qui sont insuffisants et si on
continue comme ça ça sera encore des
pertes de chance pour la population
perte de chance ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire des morts des morts et des
morts et ça c'est plus possible à cause
d'une histoire de fric alors de vrais
moyens pour l'hôpital public
nous on a décidé de se rassembler tous
les jeudis midi et jusqu'au 7 juin et
après parce que en fait il ya plus enfin
on n'est pas du tout content de ce qui
se passe là en ce moment qui seraient
les négociations et autres
nous on sait ce qu'on veut en fait on
nous demande depuis des mois une
augmentation de salaires de 300 euros
pour tous les personnels hospitaliers
ce qu'on demande aux 6 et des embauches
des embauches massives des moyens des
budgets pour couper et voilà en fait
c'est ça qu'on
ce qu'on veut c'est du début d embauche
du personnel des moyens financiers et
voilà et pour là on connaît on connaît
en fait les problèmes on connaît le
constat est en fait on veut pas de
blabla nous ce qu'on veut c'est vraiment
des moyens pour travailler correctement
parce que en fait dans l'est dans les
services là en fait en gros les salaires
ils sont très bas moi j'ai des collègues
qui n'arrivent plus à payer leur loyer
qui n'arrive plus à manger correctement